tenemos por acá la gráfica de igual a h
de equis y nos preguntan podemos aplicar
el teorema del valor intermedio a la
función h en el intervalo cerrado de
menos uno a cuatro bueno primero
marquemos el intervalo el intervalo
cerrado de menos 1 a 4 así que vamos a
recordar qué dice el teorema del valor
intermedio incluso si no recuerdas qué
dice el teorema del valor intermedio lo
que sí debes recordar es que sólo se
aplican a intervalos cerrados donde la
función es continua y tal vez estés
tentado a decir oye espera esta función
tiene una discontinuidad en un punto por
acá pero cuidado esa discontinuidad está
fuera del intervalo a nosotros nos
importa el intervalo cerrado de menos 1
a 4 donde aquí tenemos a hd menos 1 y en
x igual a 4 aquí tenemos el otro valor
de la función y puedes ver que en todo
este intervalo mi función es continua
podemos decir que sí
cumplen la primera condición sobre la
continuidad de la función en este
intervalo cerrado y por lo tanto podemos
decir que si si se puede aplicar el
teorema del valor intermedio y como si
se aplica el teorema del valor
intermedio ya que tenemos una función
continua en un intervalo cerrado podemos
decir qué htx toman cualquier valor
entre h de menos 1 y h t4 incluyendo
esos valores a simple vista parece que
hd menos 13 y h de cuatro es cero así
que por el teorema del valor intermedio
podemos decir que h tomará cualquier
valor entre menos 3 y 0 y de hecho lo
puedes ver en la gráfica incluso sólo en
esta parte de la gráfica puedes ver que
tomamos todos los valores entre menos 3
y 0 de lugo hagamos otro ejemplo ahora
nos preguntan podemos aplicar el teorema
del valor extremo a la función g en el
intervalo cerrado 0,5
así que una vez más antes de pensar en
qué dice el teorema del valor extremo
hay que recordar que de igual manera que
el teorema del valor intermedio sólo se
aplica a funciones continuas en un
intervalo cerrado así que veamos la
función jefe es continua en el intervalo
cerrado 05 bueno de 0 a 5 no claramente
tenemos una discontinuidad aquí en x
igual a 3 así que ya está podemos decir
que no podemos decir que en este
intervalo cerrado no tenemos un valor
máximo a un valor mínimo bien definido y
lo podemos ver claramente aquí no
tenemos un máximo bien definido ni un
mínimo bien definido porque tendemos en
finito y por acá tendemos a menos
infinito y por lo tanto no podemos
aplicar el teorema del valor extremo si
tuviéramos un intervalo cerrado donde la
función si fuera continua por ejemplo si
tomamos el intervalo de x igual a menos
2 a x igual a 0
déjeme ponerlo
un color que se vea ok este de aquí
entonces el teorema del valor extremo si
aplicaría podemos decir que en este
intervalo si tenemos bien definido un
máximo y un mínimo y en este caso el
máximo ocurre en el límite derecho y el
valor mínimo ocurre en el límite
izquierdo pero en el caso del problema
original donde teníamos este intervalo y
además tenemos una función que no es
continua entonces diremos que no podemos
aplicar el teorema del valor extremo
bien hagamos un último ejemplo tengo
este de aquí podemos aplicar el teorema
del valor extremo a la función f
en el intervalo cerrado de menos 5 a
menos 2 una vez más vamos al intervalo
tenemos el intervalo cerrado de menos 5
a menos 2 y aquí tenemos una función en
este intervalo y aunque tenemos una
discontinuidad en la gráfica en este
punto destaca observamos que está fuera
de este intervalo solo nos va a importar
lo que esté dentro de él
intervalo y en efecto en este intervalo
la función es continua y sólo por eso ya
sabemos que podemos aplicar el teorema
del valor extremo ya que tenemos un
máximo y un mínimo bien definidos en ese
intervalo y puedes ver que el valor
máximo pasa en f2 que parece que es
aproximadamente como menos 3.5 y el
valor mínimo pasa en ft menos 5 que
parece que es menos 4 porque esta
función está creciendo en todo este
intervalo y lo importante de este
ejercicio es reconocer la continuidad y
si la continuidad no se aplica a toda la
función no importa pero si debe
aplicarse al intervalo cerrado al que le
estemos aplicando el teorema me despido
es todo por este vídeo continuamos en el
siguiente